which is one more thing about the frogs
i was reminded reading this
you know the new york times article says
oh you know 10 years ago these people
would have been doing ayahuasca in
you know yurts in the backyards of
people in southern california and now
they're doing combo
and you know it definitely it it it
invokes an image
like i got it i'm right there um and
it also invoked for me however um
it reminded me of my very first study
abroad program not
actually at evergreen i ran a study
abroad program as you know through an
independent
field school before i started evergreen
after i got my phd
and i had students none of whom i'd met
before meeting them in panama we're in
bocas del toro
archipelago and i had students from the
us and from europe
and after one of the first days of
field work where they were supposed to
be collecting some data on their own a
couple of them a couple of
a couple of guys came back and told me
they'd licked some frogs
and it's like guys you have no idea what
you're doing
like you you heard somewhere that some
frogs will get you high
and this is really not a safe practice
really not a safe practice
but amphibians are actually really well
equipped to hurt you
and they don't have fangs like they
don't have teeth well no so
many of them the ones the ones they were
looking don't have teeth some of them do
but you know they
they don't come with spikes and horns
and claws and such
um they they come with the poisons in
their skin and not all of them are but
for
god's sake yeah you know get it get it
get it right let's do your research
it's frog roulette in the neotropics to
be yeah so
it is so first of all just to wrap
things up nicely
the idea that harassing frogs uh causes
them
to exude this substance makes perfect
sense behaviorally because in general
it doesn't take much contact with a
toxin
for a predator to realize i don't want
to eat that thing which means that
in many instances the animal will not be
killed
at the point that the predator realizes
it's made a mistake
right so you know toxins tend to be very
very bitter and in fact if i can
confess you know the uh quick and dirty
way of figuring out whether some fruit
you found in the rain forest
is uh okay to eat is to take it and
dab it on your tongue and in general the
stuff that you shouldn't eat is bitter
as
all hell and the stuff you know
spandious
what i love finding on the forest floor
which is perfectly edible and delicious
that's the scientific name of this
beautiful it's canopy tree
oh yeah with fruits um that must be
dispersed at least in part by monkeys
because
we uh we like it too
monkeys and bats i believe are the
primary uh dispersers monkeys sometimes
being lousy dispersers because they will
sit in the tree and eat
all day and drop the seeds right under
the tree which the tree could do itself
without
making a fruit bats we don't need to
send it through a monkey to do that
thanks much
right so bats are great dispersers why
because
two reasons one they fly so they tend to
if they swallow the seeds they'll crap
them out somewhere else
but they also have a very fascinating
aversion to hanging out in fruit trees
even the ones that eat only fruit don't
hang out in the fruit trees and the
interpretation of this
is that those fruit trees attract
predators looking for
fruit dispersers and so the fruit tree
is simultaneously a source of food and a
very dangerous place to be
which it's possible that the fruit trees
actually
have a branch structure that increases
the likelihood of predators to be there
in order to make the the uh fruit
frugivores nervous
so they'll leave and go do a good job of
dispersing anyway yes it's an
interesting
interesting uh story but the point is
your students who licked these frogs
probably would have the experience if
they found a particularly toxic one
would probably have the experience of
making their mouths very numb and
tasting something very bitter and
realizing they'd made a mistake
but there is the occasional numb is only
one like so numb
would be the effect from the dark poison
frogs like i have
stories about that maybe i'll share one
of them here today but some you know i
don't think combo actually produces for
instance numbness it's not going after
sensory neuron
um synapses um but
i would just point out that in the
gender batteries is really
your story but uh in the dendrobatids
there are
the occasional frog that is so
toxic that mere contact with the animal
is enough to
knock a person flat on their ass so
viola baby is terrible right
had we been in a place where that was
true i would have
obviously provided them that information
in advance and told them to stay the
hell away and in fact
across um it's since been developed
which is a terrible
tragedy or at least it was in the
process of being developed and it's
possible it got stopped but
there was this is related but not quite
the same
um the highest density known of eyelash
fibers which is just this beautiful
snake named because it has these scales
above its eyes that look like
it's look like they're wearing this like
you know fancy fake eyelashes
and they're trees tree snakes and they
come in a
plethora of colors they you know usually
um in the rest of their uh distribution
um the rest of their range they're
yellow but on the serapto peninsula
which is just a short boat right away
from this field station we were at
there's sometimes pink there's green
there's sometimes pale with some
splotches
um and i had actually one of the
students who had looked frogs earlier
ended up doing some research on these
snakes
but i was over with him for the first
several times that he was there and i
made sure
that he was at you know not acting like
a yahoo because
you just you cannot operate the same way
in a tropical forest as you do in a
temperate forest or
anywhere in a place that hasn't been
made safe for you
um on because there is there is
no one who could possibly make it safe
yep
yeah and eyelash vipers being one of
these things even those of us who are
used to dealing with poisonous snakes
right the eyelash viper is where you put
your hand which is not the usual
for such animals yeah and they're little
too and they'll you know they'll they'll
bite you
little and inconspicuous and so as you
know i have a hypothesis about what the
value of the eyelash is
so unfortunately we don't have a picture
of this animal or this would be much
more
i can't get one well like even if i
could
i don't no i can't okay um
so the eyelash viper has these little
like uh it's
scaly it's basically the same material
as the
the face of the animal and it sticks off
above the eye and these are
little vipers that hang out on
various plant parts and wait for prey
they're sitting weight
predators and being camouflaged is key
to their
their niche and so as heather mentioned
they're
tremendously large number of colors even
within
a brood as i understand it um you can
get many different colors which means
so i wish we had one of our pictures
like you and i both have taken some
beautiful pictures
but um here's here's one this isn't a
very good picture
um here's one again showing the face
yeah that's tiny though um
yeah it's not these aren't great
pictures and i i didn't prepare for this
so i don't have
i don't have any of ours um anyway keep
going oh but there there you go
that's not bad that's not bad can you
show it can you full screen
not really there we go so there you can
see the little eyelashes that stick off
above the animal's eye so the hypothesis
and again this is a hypothesis as far as
i know completely untested in fact i
don't think anybody
has taken it seriously but i didn't know
i didn't
i know i see look at you you're i'm
sorry i just remember you doing this in
class and uh
it was the first time i heard it when we
were teaching together and i think i
just started laughing but you have no
idea this warms my heart so to be the
only person who believes in something
and then you know if this turns out to
be right which i think it's really
likely yeah
i'll be thrilled but anyway that doesn't
mean it's not ridiculous it is
it's nature is ridiculous so
the hypothesis is that this animal in
order to do what it does
needs to find a place where it is
camouflaged in order to sit
and because you have many different
color forms of these
snakes within a brood you can't just
wire in
you know you're a green you're a light
green snake look for light green
places to hide because the animal
doesn't really know
what color works right because
it could be any color and so if the
genome had that programmed in you'd
somehow have to coordinate
the color of the skin with the
preference in the eye
and that's not an easy job to do so what
about having a little eyelash that
sticks up that allows the animal to look
around and
match its color to the substrate on
which it's going to sit
so it's like like why they're snakes
why don't they look at their own tail
like look i've done
that's cool but like they're snakes they
have a lot of bodies
they can look at and they're and they're
pretty much the same color okay
okay okay but if the animal is looking
around
by definition it will have its eyelashes
right where it's looking right
whereas having to sit somewhere and pull
its tail up and match it up to some
flower
while that would also be a cool
adaptation i don't think it's nearly as
cool as having just a little thing
so that this makes predictions one
prediction is that the eyelashes are
within the view
of the animal enough to work this way
and you're going to find this out
through interviews or
[Laughter]
yes that's how i'm going to find it i'm
going to ask the animals if they can see
their eyelashes
but uh also the prediction would be that
the eyelashes are never of a different
hue than the animal right true so uh
anyway things like that so this is how
we entertain ourselves it is
it is this and pinheaded truth so there
you go
um oh the last thing yeah yes
as long as we're on the topic um
amphibians
toxic our newts our local newts here are
maybe the most toxic
pound-for-pound animal on planet earth
which was discovered
through an accident where some hunters i
believe
had accidentally scooped a newt into
a coffee pot and then boiled the water
to make coffee
and were found dead and this alerted
people these must be very toxic animals
they searched and something like
um there's enough toxin in an individual
nuke to kill
50 average people something like that
and i believe
the story is not specious that um the
people in north america who then did
work on terricogranulosis
and um and isolated the molecule
which they called terrycotoxin based on
the genus name of the newt the latin
name of the new tariqa
um went to present their work at some
big
toxicology conference or some such some
few decades ago this was this isn't 100
years ago this is fairly recently
uh and in the audience i think i'm
getting the details right and i think
this is a true story
um in the audience were the japanese
researchers who had worked
on uh the toxin that the puffer fish
uh the genus for which is tetrodus i
think i may have that quite a little bit
wrong but they
actually were presenting at the same
conference to trototoxin uh which is the
toxin of the puffer fish
and i don't remember who was up first
but either the tariqa toxin guys with
the newts or the detroiter toxin guys
with the puffer fish toxin
were up there presenting and the other
people were in the audience and they
looked at the molecular description the
chemical description of the
of the toxin went oh my god it's the
same thing
so it turns out puffer fish in the
western pacific and
uh newts on the west coast of north
america separated by
a large pacific ocean across which the
newts cannot
cross and the puffer fish do not cross
have convergently evolved exactly the
same toxin
right which makes a weird kind of sense
because all of these toxins are
basically
interference molecules with the
physiology of critters
and to the extent that critters are
variations on a theme there's a limited
number of molecules you could build and
there will be selection for that which
most effectively disrupts the
creatures in question and so it's not
surprising that selection again and
again
finds well you would expect it to find
analogs you would expect to disrupt the
same system
what is a little surprising is that it
finds exactly the same structure that
interfaces with
right and in that case not because as
with as i already mentioned the
dark poison frogs in the new world the
gender batteds and the mantelas the
poison photos of madagascar
have converged upon exactly the same
lipophilic alkaloids
but we can trace that to an
environmental similarity which is that
the building blocks for those alkalides
are in
the alkaloids or in the mites and the
ants that they eat even though
the species of ants and mites like the
species of frogs themselves are complete
are
so distantly related in madagascar
versus the new world
despite having a goddaudan distribution
that is that is shared but we're talking
about
you know tens to you know well over 100
million years since gondwana has been
separated
anyway that you know biogeography for
another time but yep um
which is one more thing about um about
these frog toxins when i was
um when i was in the business of
tattooing frogs which i was
i remember this one for a spell um only
because i needed to mark them in order
to know who was who in order to do the
behavioral work that i was doing
on them and i tried putting little
beaded waistbands around them and i
tried a number of things and none of it
worked in part um
it turns out the frogs have neither
necks nor wastes really um
or if they have wastes that if you cinch
something tight enough you're gonna hurt
the frog
and these are little tiny frogs so i
ended up
tattooing them which didn't please them
too much
and you have to be really careful
they've only got two layers of skinned
r3 so you have to be very very careful i
had this little
handheld tattoo machine that i was part
of my field gear in madagascar
but much like the people in the
brazilian amazon who use various toxins
as um you know as tips for their darts
or
as you know purgatives for their own
health
you have to aggravate the frog in order
to get them to start producing this
white milky toxin on their skin
and i was never trying to that wasn't
part of my research i wasn't studying
their um their biochemistry or their
toxins but
what i found was that when a frog was
particularly squirmy and i had to really
you know hold it for a while in order to
get it tattooed
that even when i wasn't aware of it if i
had spent a morning tattooing frogs
and then was uncareful in the way that
many of us discovered we were at the
beginning of kovid and
often touching her face and such that if
i touched
my fingers that had been on the frogs to
my lips or any mucous membrane or any
cut
i would get a quick burning followed by
numbness that would last for anywhere
from
a few minutes to up to an hour or two in
one case and that this was very clearly
the toxin the lipophilic alkaloids in
these frogs
um that was doing its work which is as i
mentioned earlier blocking
the synaptic transmission of sensory
neurons hence the numbness
the numbness perfect sense yeah yeah i
should just say because certain people
will be wondering
yes you had a tattoo gun on your
study island in madagascar and because
the days are long and there's not a
whole lot to do
you also at one point did my trap stamp
and i think you did very excellent work
oh yeah
are you gonna show it uh not not today
you